so I've been a little m.i.a lately I
haven't done a garyvaynerchuk.com video
with quite a while I wanted to kind of
let you know what's been going on kind
of been in the trenches I think a lot of
people talk a big game and talk about
stuff and put out content and that's all
great sometimes I'm just going to put
your head down and execute the head
Marcus the guerilla camerawork this
little way put your head down execute
I'm in that mindset right now I think
it's the real world is very underrated
in our internet business you know
sometimes you've got to take meetings
shake hands
Network get out there set up things make
stuff happen I'm very much in the mix
stuff happen mode right now where I am
today is actually anymore at the new up
vaynermedia
and really what I'm trying to do
get some execution down on launching
this new consulting company or some
other things as well and very much
focusing on my crushing books so a
little quiet on the GE comm videos but
it's probably because I'm executing on
what I preach which is put your head
down shut up
no I think I'm gonna close my Yap a
little bit and make stuff happen and
that's what I'm trying to do because
you're all doing well I'd love for you
guys to comment down below and let me
know what you guys are crushing on right
now and and I wish you and your family
nothing but the best and now I'm going
to stop and get back to a little hustle
I said a couple once about who's gonna
do this I think go the beer I'm gonna
work on that as well